- Very excited to welcome you
to the Third Annual Seong-Yawng
Park Memorial Lecture,
Seong-Yawng Park, Graduate School of 1965,
and Marguerite Clark
Park Memorial Lecture.
We were really just getting
started with the Park Lecture
a few years ago, and then COVID happened.
So although the lecture's been
around for about five years,
this is only the third one,
and I will let our chair, Hwansoo Kim,
introduce our speaker.
But just briefly, I'd like
to tell you a little bit
about the lecture itself.
The Seong-Yawng Park and
Marguerite Clark Park Lecture
was made possible by
a really generous gift
from the Estate of the Park family.
And so the principal objective of it
is to foster the study of Korea at Yale
by bringing recognition
to the Korean Peninsula
and its affairs and achievements
to Yale and the wider community.
And, you know, I'd like
to just briefly say
that Prof. Dr. Park was a really generous
and insightful alumni, alum for Yale.
He graduated from,
he earned a PhD here in 1965 in Economics,
and then he went on to teach
at the University of
California, Berkeley school
before expanding his father's company
into one of the top
conglomerates in Korea.
But importantly for Yale,
he really had a very,
a really active role in
promoting Yale in Korea, right?
And as we work now to
build our Korea program,
that's really an honor to be
able to continue that legacy.
So among the other things
that he did at Yale,
he was a member
of President's Council on
International Activities.
He was on the Board of Advisors
for the Yale Economic Growth Center,
and served for many years as the president
of the Yale Club of Korea.
And so, in many ways he was really
Yale's biggest champion in Korea,
and we're really so glad to be
able to continue that legacy.
But with that, I'll turn things
over to Prof. Hwansoo Kim,
Professor of Religious Studies,
to introduce our speaker today.
- Thank you so much for coming
on a very chilly day. (laughs)
So it's my tremendous honor and pleasure
to able to introduce my senior
colleague, Prof. Jin Park.
Dr. Park is currently Professor
and the Chair of the Department
of Philosophy and Religion
at American University.
She received her B.A. and M.A.
from Yonsei University
in Seoul, South Korea,
and her PhD from the State
University of New York
at Stony Brook in 1998.
Prof. Park is not only a prominent scholar
of Korean Buddhist Studies,
but also a leading scholar of
Korean Studies in the West.
It's true that Prof.
Robert Buswell (chuckles)
has been the towering
figure of Korean Buddhism,
but he's retiring this
semester, (chuckles)
so while Prof. Park is nowhere
near retirement herself,
and while she might
disagree with me on this,
but I would say that
very soon she will become
the most senior scholar of our field.
Likewise, in terms of
Korean Studies broadly,
she's now one of the most
accomplished female scholars
in the field as well.
So for me, personally,
for the past 15 years,
Prof. Park has been a close
intellectual interlocutor,
colleague and mentor,
deeply influencing and guiding
my research in many ways.
Her interdisciplinary
and versatile research
explores Korean and East Asian Buddhism,
intercultural philosophy,
modern Korean philosophy,
and intercultural ethics,
focusing on the intersections
of gender, violence,
the politics of discrimination
and marginalization,
and narrative identity.
She is a very prolific writer,
having published three books,
six edited and co-edited volumes,
and more than 60 articles
and book chapters so far.
So in the first book,
titled "Buddhism and
Postmodernism: Zen, Huayan,
and the Possibility of
Buddhist Postmodern Ethics,"
published in 2008,
Prof. Park dispels century-old
suspicions of Buddhism
as a religion of nothingness
or one that disregard philosophers.
And she offers the ethics of tension
as a potential ethical paradigm
drawn from Zen and Huayan Buddhism
and postmodern philosophy,
with a special focus on Jacques
Derrida's deconstruction.
The next book, titled "Reflections
of a Zen Buddhist Nun,"
published in 2014, is a
meticulous translation
of a bestseller book
published in Korean in 1960
by Kim Iryŏp, a writer,
first-generation Korean feminist,
Buddhist nun, and philosopher,
as you can see on the screen,
who presents a creative interpretation
of Buddhist philosophy and practice.
The third one, "Women
and Buddhist Philosophy:
Engaging Zen Master Kim Iryŏp,"
is a sequel to "Reflections
of a Zen Buddhist Nun,"
but a broader, in-depth
analysis of Kim Iryŏp's oeuvre.
Prof. Park proposes a new
mode of philosophizing
based on the discussion
of Kim Iryŏp's life
experience and worldview.
She terms this new mode of philosophizing
as narrative philosophy,
which engages itself
with a narrative discourse
of our daily experiences
instead of relying heavily
on theorization and abstraction.
So I'm sure Prof. Park
will elaborate more on this
in today's talk.
As I said, Prof. Park is
also editor and co-editor
of five volumes:
"Approaches to Chan, Sŏn,
Zen Studies," in 2022,
"Makers of Modern Korean Buddhism," 2010,
"Merleau-Ponty and Buddhism," 2010,
and also "Buddhism and
Deconstructions," 2006,
"Comparative Political Theory
and Cross-Cultural Philosophy," in 2009.
And in fact, she and I
have recently finished
another co-edited volume,
called "New Perspectives
in Modern Korean Buddhism:
Institution, Gender and Secular Society,"
which will come out by SUNY this December.
Prof. Park is a recipient
of many numerous grants
and has taught as a visiting professor
in Korea, Japan, Canada, and Germany.
She's equally active in
professional leadership and service.
She currently serves as the Vice President
of the American Academy of Religion.
In fact, she's the first East Asianist
to be elected to the position
in the Academy's 100-year history.
She's also the president
of the North American Korean
Philosophy Association,
and also the president
of the Society for Asian
and Comparative Philosophy.
So it's so great to have you over here.
Without further ado,
please join me in
welcoming Prof. Jin Park.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
Okay, can you hear me? Good.
Thank you very much for
the generous introduction
and thank you for having me here.
I'm really happy to be here
and sharing my research
with the Yale community.
So after the pandemic,
even though we are still wearing masks,
just, in-person event is both exciting
and a little bit worrisome, right?
So I know.
So in the department, we just
did the first in-person event
since the pandemic, a couple of weeks ago.
It's exciting, but at the same
time, something is different.
So, but anyway, I'm really
glad to be here in person,
not on Zoom.
And I'd like to share
with you about my research
on women and then women and Buddhism.
So as Prof. Kim mentioned,
this is research that
I did for a long time,
and a little bit of a
genesis of this research.
So after I finished my dissertation
on Buddhism and postmodernism,
my focus at that time, in
Buddhism, was premodern.
I was working on
a 13th century Korean Sŏn master, Chinul.
So after I finished my dissertation,
I began to think about
modern Korean Buddhism.
What happened in Buddhism in modern time?
Because after all, I compared
13th century Sŏn Buddhism
with 20th century French philosophy.
So what happened to Buddhism nowadays?
So I began my research on
modern Korean Buddhism and,
believe it or not, about 20 years ago,
the modern Korean Buddhism was
not studied, even in Korea.
It was a very rare occasion.
It changed rapidly for the past 20 years.
But anyway, as I started working
on modern Korean Buddhism,
naturally a question arose:
what happened to women?
Where are they?
The available materials are all
about Buddhist monks, right,
or man, obviously, as usual.
And I couldn't find the
materials on Korean nuns.
In terms of number, actually,
there are a little bit
more Korean Buddhist nuns
than monks in Korea, but
then we don't have materials.
So after kind of struggling
to find the materials,
I came across a book, which
is not an academic book,
but a book written by a journalist.
He now got his PhD and
he became an academic,
but he was a reporter
in a Buddhist newspaper,
and he was interested
in, for whatever reason,
interested in Buddhist nuns.
So he kind of began to run
a series on a newspaper,
introducing Korean Buddhist
nuns in modern period,
starting from the very beginning,
which was in 1910, 1920.
So each chapter in the book
has about 10 pages, 15 pages,
about the life,
and then when the person
became a Buddhist nun,
what the person did, and died, right?
And when I got to Kim Iryŏp's
section, that's only 15 pages.
I read it and thought, "Wow,
this figure is interesting.
There might be something."
But because it's only 15 pages,
I couldn't kind of tell much about it.
So there begin the journey,
or there began the journey.
So I began to look up the materials.
I've been to all the kind
of secondhand bookstores
and then library book copies,
and so on and so forth.
And it was an interesting kind of journey.
So as I just told you, that I encounter,
I discovered Kim Iryŏp
as a Buddhist scholar.
But once I began to talk about Kim Iryŏp,
my parents' generation,
they all know Kim Iryŏp.
Not because they are Buddhist scholar.
Because Kim Iryŏp was a
celebrity in her time, right?
So that really gave me
also another thought.
If she was that much influential
for my parents' generation,
how come I don't know her,
even though I'm a Buddhist scholar?
So a lot of questions
kind of came to my mind,
and over the almost two decades,
my questions about Kim
Iryŏp, Kim Iryŏp's works
changes and edited,
so there are kind of a lot of
different kind of questions
and issues I explored with Kim Iryŏp.
And that was also
because Kim Iryŏp's life
itself is panoramic.
There are different dimensions in her life
and each stage kind of gave
us new kind of questions.
So in this presentation,
I will give you kind of a,
I will tell you about Kim Iryŏp's life
from the beginning
almost to the end, right?
And that story I'd like to
give you within the big frame.
So these are two questions
I want to kind of ask
in this presentation.
First one has to do
with women and Buddhism.
So, how and why do women
engage with Buddhism?
So I mean, each individual
has a different reason
to learn Buddhism or practice Buddhism
and so on and so forth.
Now, my question here is that,
whether women has specific
reasons or journey
which is different from
their male counterpart.
That's one question, which
is related to, obviously,
gender issue, and women's issue,
and Buddhism and gender issue.
And I'd like to expand the
scope a little bit more.
And the second question then,
women in modern Korean
intellectual history.
As you will see shortly,
definitely Kim Iryŏp
was one of the main figure,
from my perspective,
in modern Korean intellectual history.
But where is she in the history
of modern intellectual kind of history?
So the second question would be,
women in modern Korean
intellectual history,
how and where do they meet?
So I'd like to address these questions
by going through Kim
Iryŏp's life and thought.
Kim Iryŏp was born 1896 and died 1971,
and obviously, Korean Buddhist nun-thinker
So there are different kinds
of phases in Kim Iryŏp life,
which kind of shows us
different intellectual
aspects of Kim Iryŏp.
So the first one is her
Christian background.
Kim Iryŏp's father was a Christian pastor.
And look at the date. She was born 1896.
So her father was a first-generation
Korean Protestant pastor, right?
And obviously, he was very faithful.
Kim Iryŏp describe her
father, in one of her essay,
that he is most faithful Christian
in the entire Korea, right?
And her mother, obviously, was
also very faithful Christian.
Growing up in this kind
of a Christian family,
Kim Iryŏp herself was obviously
very faithful Christian.
And she envisioned her future
as a Christian missionary
when she was only seven
or eight years old.
She said that she was gonna go to a place
where the people do not know about God.
She's gonna send God's message.
Well, that was good.
But then eventually,
during her teenage years,
she began to have doubts
about Christianity.
And I think these doubts she had
were kind of doubts any
Christian could have had.
So the questions like,
if God created the world,
why are there so many
bad things in the world,
and so on and so forth, right?
These are the questions that theologians
discussed for centuries.
But when Kim Iryŏp tried to ask
this question to her father,
who was a very conservative evangelist,
he stopped her and told her,
"You think about that kind of thing
because your faith is not strong enough.
Pray. That is the only answer."
So this kind of attitude
of her father backfired.
So because she could not get
an answer to her questions,
eventually she lost her
faith in Christianity
around, she was late-teenage years.
Then after that, until
she encountered Buddhism,
then for 10 years, she didn't
have a religion, right?
Another kind of important
aspect of Kim Iryŏp's life
is her education.
So Kim Iryŏp received
education all the way up
to what now is called college.
Ewha Haktang, which opened in 1886,
was the first women's higher education,
established by a Christian
missionary, obviously.
But think about this.
The beginning of the 20th
century, in Confucian Korea,
women were not supposed to get educated.
Even when the opportunity
opened like this,
the first year that Ewha Haktang opened,
there was no student,
and then there came one student
who actually, eventually,
became a translator for the Royal family.
So in Confucian Korea,
educating women is a bad idea, right,
because women does not need an education
to be a good wife and mother.
But Kim Iryŏp was one
of this first generation
of Korean women who
received public education,
Western-style education, for women.
And Kim Iryŏp credits this
kind of whole opportunity
to get educated, to her
parents' Christianity.
I think that's true.
Because her parents kind
of were faithful Christian,
they learned more about
the Western culture
where women's education studied earlier.
So her mother told her that,
"Even though you are a daughter,
I will educate you like any sons."
And her mother was criticized
by the village people.
"Why are you educating a girl?
What's good about doing that?"
But she did get education.
And after she finished at Ewha Hakdang,
she also had an opportunity
to study in Japan
from 1919 to 1920.
As many Koreans nowadays come to U.S.
to get an advanced education,
during the early 20th century,
many Koreans went to Japan
to receive advanced kind of education,
and Kim Iryŏp went to Japan.
And I believe it was in Japan
she really got this idea
about the women's movement.
So as soon as she came
back from Japan, 1920,
she kind of established with
other, kind of her friends,
the journal titled
"Sinyŏja," meaning New Woman.
She became the editor-in-chief,
and this journal is credited
as the first one published by women
for the benefit of women.
So that's a big thing. So that's 1920.
And she was the editor-in-chief,
which is big thing, right?
And here you clearly see
the kind of influence
of Japanese feminist activists.
Because if you know the Japanese case,
then in Japan, early 1910, 1911,
there were a group of female intellectuals
who were very much actively involved
with the women's movement.
And Hiratsuka Raichō
was the leading figure
who created the journal called "Seitō."
Seitō literally means Bluestockings.
You know, the Bluestockings, right,
which in kind of 18th century in Europe
then meant a kind of
radical kind of woman.
Well, at the beginning,
both men and women were bluestockings.
So literally, it means a
kind of women's movement.
When Kim Iryŏp came back to Korea,
not only she created journal "Sinyŏja,"
but she also created a forum
in which women get all together,
discuss about women's issue,
with the name of which
the group was Ch'ŏngt'ap.
Now, the Chinese and
Korean, Korean and Japanese,
(speaking in foreign language)
has a different pronunciation.
So "Seitō" in Korean
pronunciation is Ch'ŏngt'ap.
So Kim Iryŏp definitely
used that expression.
But interestingly, Kim Iryŏp,
I don't know whether she was
not aware of this expression,
bluestockings, or she
didn't like bluestockings,
so she changed the second character,
so meaning of her forum became Blue Tower
instead of Bluestockings.
But here we clearly see that
the Japanese new women's
influence on Kim Iryŏp.
So if you see her life in
the 1920s, from 1920 to 1928,
Iryŏp was a very engaged writer,
women's movement activist,
and a public intellectual.
Here you see Kim Iryŏp at the
center with Korean writers.
When I show this to my
students, I ask them,
"Who do you think is Kim Iryŏp?"
And students always say, "Center," right?
"Center is Kim Iryŏp."
(chuckles) I don't know how
they kind of notice that,
but the woman with
glasses, that's Kim Iryŏp.
And then also here,
Kim Iryŏp was giving a
public lecture in 1962.
Prof. Kim kind of showed me this picture,
led me to this picture.
So this is something, that
woman gave a public lecture
in Korea in 1920s.
Now,
in the inaugural,
the kind of first issue of "New Women,"
this is kind of what we read.
So what are their demands?
So here is the first:
economic independence, obviously, right?
Second, rationalization and
simplification of family system,
because family life is a
kind of core of women's life.
Third, rejection of a
male-dominated traditional thought.
Fourth, a call for the stronger awareness
of women's responsibility and duties.
The statement is a little bit ambiguous.
So right, what are the
responsibilities and duties?
Fifth, campaigns by women's organizations
and female students for Old Women,
so that they could get aware
of various women's issues,
including health and child-education.
So here, it could be a little bit radical,
but it's not really radical-radical
in terms of demands of women
for their freedom, right?
Well, what Kim Iryŏp
became criticized by the society
and under notoriety, was
through her challenging
about the body politics of Korean society.
So Kim Iryŏp said
that society's control
of feminine sexuality
in the name of virginity and
chastity is a visible form
of gender discrimination
in Korean society,
and Kim Iryŏp demanded sexual
freedom, freedom to love,
and freedom to get divorced.
So here you begin to see that,
how Korean society in 1920s,
within the Confucian tradition,
would accept this kind of demand.
When I first read this demand
of Kim Iryŏp, I thought,
"Wow, how was she able to be
this much radical in 1920s Korea?"
I mean, even the end of 20th
century, early 21st century,
in Korea, this could be a radical demand.
And then I learned that, well,
this is not only Kim Iryŏp's idea,
but this was a kind of general trend
in the New Women movement,
which was based on the
Swedish thinker, Ellen Key,
but I'm not gonna go there.
But anyway, so this
was Kim Iryŏp's demand,
known as "New Theory of
Chastity," (speaks in Korean).
But what she said
is not that we should get rid of chastity.
That's not what Kim Iryŏp said, right?
Chastity is obviously
a visible form of gender
discrimination in Korean society,
but she's not saying that
therefore we should get rid of it.
But she redefined the meaning of chastity.
Now, what she says, is that
chastity should be defined
as a maximum state of
love for one's lover,
not a moral rule that
society impose on individual.
And I think it makes good sense,
because what she claim is,
that if somebody is in
love with someone else,
naturally, the person
will maintain chastity,
be faithful to the
person, even when society
doesn't tell the person,
"You should be faithful."
When the love is not strong enough,
then there comes a problem.
So it's not an issue that
society control people
by making a rule.
And Kim Iryŏp thought
that this kind of idea
is not only for women,
but for men as well.
So here I'm quoting a passage
from "My View on Chastity" article.
Quote, "We, new women and new men,"
here you see that she is
addressing both men and women,
"who want to do away
with all the conventions,
traditions, concepts,
and who are determined
to bring attention to a new
and fresh concept of life,
cannot but strongly
resist, among other things,
the traditional morality on sex,
which has ignored our personalities
as well as our individual
characteristics."
So here you clearly see already
Kim Iryŏp's desire to really
maintain her personal space,
which is free from social constraints.
Well, would the Korean society allow that?
That's a really big question.
So Kim Iryŏp was part of
a women's movement group,
known as New Women,
and New Women was not
just a Korean phenomenon.
It's a global phenomenon
you see in the U.S., 1890s,
in Japan, 1910s, and Korea, 1920s.
And in the Korean context,
they usually have several
different types of new women.
And one of the first type
is a liberalist new woman,
to which Kim Iryŏp belong.
So their demand is really,
has a lot to do with sexual freedom, okay?
So liberalist new women,
they demanded individual
freedom and freedom to love
and freedom to get divorced
(speaking in Korean).
So there are three major
figures in this context:
Kim Iryŏp, and Na Hyesŏk,
who was a good friend of Kim Iryŏp,
who worked together with
Kim Iryŏp in women's issues,
who was known as the first female painter
in modern painting in Korea.
She was a really promising painter.
So I gave one, the
"Self Portrait" in 1928.
Perhaps you notice a certain
kind of very fauvistic,
impressionist, I think, I don't know.
She studied in Japan early on,
from a very wealthy family.
But eventually, she had
a problem with her family
and her marriage and
she died on the street.
And another figure is Kim Myŏngsun,
who was also known as
the first female poet
in Western-style poetry,
the first female writer in modern Korea,
and an actor and journalist.
So these women all had this,
"The first Korean woman
to this and to do that."
But Kim Myŏngsun also died.
She had a mental problem
later and died on the street.
So you see that their
ending was not happy ending,
if you just look at the ending itself.
But that's also the issue
that we need to reconsider.
So what happens here?
Kim Iryŏp's challenge to society
in terms of sexual freedom,
and Na Hyesŏk and Kim Myŏngsun,
these new Korean new women,
first generation of Korean feminists,
this is exactly the case
of value collision, right?
Two different values collide each other.
For the New Women, morality
that subjugates women to men
and limits women's life
to that of a wife and mother, is immoral.
And there is a journal in
which a New Woman says this.
Social morality is immoral
because the social morality impose women
to do only some thing and
then limits women's freedom.
However, from the society's point of view,
the new women who challenged
the traditional virtue of
women and morality for women,
assigned by the society,
is immoral and they are destructive.
They are dangerous.
So they are dangerous
women. They are bad women.
So until very recently, until
the end of 20th century,
these liberalist New Women,
they were called by all bad names.
Some people even called them
"high society call girl,"
because they talk about
sexuality in public space.
And people, even nowadays, say
that their lives are failure.
They failed. Why?
Because Na Hyesŏk's life was a failure
because she divorced and
died alone on the street.
Kim Myŏngsun's life was a failure,
since she failed with her love affairs
and died in a mental hospital.
And Kim Iryŏp's life was a failure,
since she failed in her
marriage and love affairs
and joined the monastery.
And when I read this passage,
always I find this is really
strange, right? (chuckles)
So joining the monastery is
like dying on the street.
So in other words, the
lives and even the deaths
of the New Women were judged
by the patriarchal ideology.
Not only their lives,
but even their death.
Here, I really want to ask,
what does it mean when we say
that somebody's life's a failure?
What are the standard
measurements for that?
Who make the standards?
Who make the judgment?
Can someone's life be judged
by just looking at the end
or one aspect of it?
We all know that our lives are messy.
There're all kind of
elements in there, right?
So I think this is very
important kind of issues
we need to think about,
which also apply to our society right now.
The evaluation of the New
Women's lives and deaths
by their society evidence
that values of one's life
and one's identity
was strictly controlled
by mainstream discourse.
The mainstream discourse
of Korean society says
that women's lives should be like this:
you should get married,
you should be a wife,
you should be a mother, and die.
Is that success?
(audience chuckling)
If not, you are a problem, right?
Individuals in such a society
do not have much room to
creatively engage with their lives.
There are different lives possible, right?
So Kim Iryŏp became keenly aware
of the problems of leading
a life in such a condition.
So during the 1920s, it looks like
Kim Iryŏp was thinking that,
"I can change society."
That's what women activists did, right?
"I can change society, I
can change social norms,
and then I can free myself
from this patriarchal society."
And eventually she seems to realize that
that's not exactly the end,
that wouldn't be sufficient.
There must be something deeper
than social constraints,
and that's the moment Kim Iryŏp
turns from social activist
to religious practitioner.
So around 1928,
Kim Iryŏp began to practice
the Buddhist meditation.
As I told you before, Kim
Iryŏp was a Christian.
She never knew anything about Buddhism.
She never practiced meditation.
But then suddenly, she kind
of gradually moved there.
In 1933, she joined the
monastery, became a Buddhist nun.
When she joined the monastery,
obviously Korean society
wouldn't trust her,
and said, "Well, she escaped to monastery.
She will come back soon."
No, she didn't.
Right? She didn't.
And then she was a major figure
in Korean Buddhist nuns'
community until her death in 1971.
So some people say that Kim
Iryŏp joined the monastery
because she failed in her love affairs.
And I say, "Well, if
failing in love affairs
means that you have to go to monastery,
almost everybody should have
joined the monastery, right?"
(audience chuckles)
How many people doesn't have
that kind of experience?
So looking at (indistinct)
kind of presentation
about Kim Iryŏp's life, you could see that
there seems to be two distinctive phases
in Kim Iryŏp's life,
and scholars have been claiming that.
In other words, there is a
rupture in Kim Iryŏp's life,
and the rupture happens, her (indistinct),
her joining the monastery.
So before she joined the monastery,
she was a feminist
activist, public figure,
who demanded sexual freedom.
And after she joined the
monastery, she was a Sŏn Zen master
who led the frugal life of a monastic.
I mean, monastery in Korea, it should be,
yeah, should be poor.
I mean, basically monastics
are backwards, traditionally.
In 1930s, '40s, '50s, Korean
monastery was, it looks like
really, really kind of
poor at that time, right?
And Kim Iryŏp led that life.
But from the very beginning,
I claim that that two
phases of Kim Iryŏp life,
Kim Iryŏp as a feminist activist,
Kim Iryŏp as a Sŏn Master,
they are not totally two different,
separate kind of aspects
of Kim Iryŏp's life.
These two aspects of Kim Iryŏp's life
has kind of one thread, continuing theme,
which is a search for freedom.
She wanted to be free from
the patriarchal society,
and then she wanted to
be free from even that,
there's something, the
existential kind of binding
as human beings, and by finding freedom,
she wants to be an authentic human being.
And that's my claim.
And so in looking at Kim
Iryŏp's Buddhism now,
the first question one can ask
is the relationship between
Buddhism and feminism.
In American Buddhist scholarship as well,
this issue of relationship
between women and Buddhism,
or Buddhism and feminism,
have been kind of a hot topic for a while.
And some people claim
that Buddhism and feminism
are not compatible.
Why?
Because in Buddhism, nothing
has permanent essence.
Everything exists through
causes and conditions.
Therefore Buddhist concept
of self is no-self.
In other words, there is no
permanent, independent self
in an individual.
What we call "self" is combination
of all these causes and conditions.
Therefore it is called a no-self.
On the other hand, this claims,
well, women in a patriarchal
society do not have identity.
When Buddhism claim
no-self, that doesn't help,
because women need to
find the self to lose it.
Against this kind of a claim,
Kim Iryŏp definitely demonstrate
Buddhism can help women
to liberate themselves.
And that's one of the ways of
reading Kim Iryŏp's Buddhism.
So how?
One of the ways Kim Iryŏp
kind of used Buddhism,
Buddhist concept of self,
for her feminists agenda
is to reinterpret the
concept of Buddhist no-self.
Kim Iryŏp introduce two types of self.
One is called small-self, soa.
The other is called
great-self, or big-self, tae'a.
In other words, the kind of everyday self,
which is gendered and
which confines individuals
within their boundaries,
is a fragmented self.
Iryŏp calls this self, small-self,
the kind of gendered self.
Woman, that is small-self as well.
On the other hand, based on Buddhist idea,
Iryŏp claims that once one realizes
a provisional nature of this
limited vision of the self,
one finds the Buddhist no-self,
a self that has capacity to
creatively engage with the life.
That is what is called great-self.
So here, the great-I is I who realize
that women's namelessness
in patriarchal society
is not their real self.
One has enormous capacity
to create one's identity,
which is much bigger than
any kind of confinement
that is imposed by human body
or physical environment
or social norms, right?
So the great-I is a
vision of the individual
who has a capacity to challenge
the mainstream discourse,
which imposes a fixed
identity to individuals
based on the categories an individual
might have to belong to based
on one's society, right?
So for Kim Iryŏp, the
patriarchal Korean society's
imposing of the gender identity "woman"
is a small-self, right?
But Kim Iryŏp thought that everybody,
it's not only just women,
everybody has a capacity to
creatively engage with life
in their own way.
If we translate, interpret this,
the claim of Kim Iryŏp in 1960s,
to our 21st century American society,
then we can say that great-I
is the I that can challenge
the discriminatory treatment
of one's identity, be it
related to gender, race,
sexual orientation, or social class.
So great-I has to do with the power
and strength to define
one's own self freely.
And in doing that,
definitely one needed to
challenge the status quo
because status quo does not always
kind of give you the life
and definition of the self
you think who you are.
So in a way, I think this is
a very strong kind of argument
Kim Iryŏp is making
after her kind of years
of Buddhist practice.
And she defines
the characteristics of the
great-self as creativity.
And I think it makes a lot of sense
because if you want to
engage with your identity
and your life,
away from the kind of a fixed identity
imposed by the society,
you need a creative engagement with life.
And the exercise of creativity
is Iryŏp's vision of Buddhist practice
and also her advice to women
who search for freedom and authentic self.
Here I kind of mix two
very important aspects
of Kim Iryŏp's Buddhism.
The first one is that
exercise of creativity
is Kim Iryŏp's vision
of Buddhist practice,
and not many Buddhist
practitioners or Buddhist scholars
or Buddhist teachers use
this expression, creativity,
as a kind of way of practicing Buddhism.
And one of the interesting
parts Kim Iryŏp's Buddhism
is that her interpretation
of Buddhism is very unique
in her use of language,
expressions like this.
I don't know where it came from.
Partly I think it also has to do with
her background in Christianity,
but I'm yet to find all
the kind of influence,
or simply her genius, right?
Also, her advice to women's issues.
So she is advising women,
if you want to have freedom from gender
in a patriarchal society,
you first need to be able
to find your own self, the creativity.
And Kim Iryŏp even interpret
the Buddha in this way.
So I'm quoting:
"The Buddha is a being who
fully exercised the 'creativity'
with which each being was endowed.
A creator is not a special being.
Even an insect can be a creator
if it recovers its original mind."
So this is a kind of full declaration
about the individual's capacity
to form his, her, their own life
without being constrained
by external forces.
And she also uses this
expression "culture."
When creativity, creative
activity really get together
and appear in a more physical
form, it becomes culture.
So she said this quote:
"I was aware that to
be a person of culture
meant to be a direct
disciple of the Buddha,
who is the 'great person of culture,'
and that was why I joined the monastery."
And this is another very
Kim Iryŏp-like expression.
The Buddha is "the great
person of culture."
You know, which means, for Kim Iryŏp,
Buddha is the one who 100% exercise
his creativity, freedom.
Now, here Kim Iryŏp kind of
goes back to Christianity.
I told you that Kim Iryŏp
gave up Christianity
late-teenage years, and she
didn't talk about Christianity
further (indistinct) until late 1950s.
At that time, she was
already in her sixties.
And partly, I think,
that has to do with her
relationship with her father.
Her father was a faithful Christian.
Christianity is her father's life,
and Kim Iryŏp had an
unusually close relationship
with her father.
Some of you might know
that in Confucian society,
father figure is very kind of distant.
Kim Iryŏp and Kim Iryŏp's father,
they were very close.
And it looks like, for Kim Iryŏp,
criticizing Christianity
would've been something similar
to criticizing her father's
entire life, right?
Perhaps because of that and other reasons,
she didn't talk about
Christianity for a long time.
And by the end of the 1950s,
perhaps she now felt confident.
She talked about God and
redefined Christianity and God
from Buddhist perspective.
And she says, "God is not
a creator of the world
but a being that fully
exercised creativity."
And she said, "If you say that God
is the creator of the world,
then you are kind of insulting
God, because in that case,
God is responsible for all
the bad things in the world."
Obviously, theologians have
all kind of explanation
about this, but that's Kim
Iryŏp's kind of approach.
And she put God and the Buddha
in a kind of same kind of a category,
and saying that the Buddha and God
originate from the same seed.
So God is not the object of one's worship,
but, rather, a model or
evidence that a being is,
in its ultimate sense,
wholesome and not fragmented.
At the end of her life, at the last book,
which was published in 1964,
and Kim Iryŏp died in 1971,
she's kind of focusing
on this expression "life
force" (speaking in Korean).
At the final stage of her life,
Iryŏp focuses her philosophy
on "life" or "life force."
"Life" is what is shared
by all the beings,
human, non-human, even inanimate beings,
and that is a foundation of existence.
To be aware of one's existence
through its foundation,
the life force, is one's way
to get engaged with one's
existential ecology.
By focusing on the life,
which is really bottom
foundation of existence,
Iryŏp was claiming the
equality of all beings.
And in this case, all beings
include not only humans,
human animal, nonhuman animals,
and inanimate beings, right?
She's talking about,
even a kind of piece of
broken tile has freedom.
So this is a kind of a,
it's a symbolic statement,
but it really tells us her confidence
about the equality of all
existing beings, right?
So because she was
such a kind of prominent figure
in women's movement before
she joined the monastery,
one of the questions constantly raised
about Kim Iryŏp's life and
thought, is this question,
what happened to women's
movement to Kim Iryŏp
after she joined the monastery?
In fact, she never explicitly
talked about women's movement
after she joined the monastery,
even though I read Kim Iryŏp's Buddhism
in a very much kind of
feminist perspective.
Now, there's another way
of approaching this issue.
I mean, women's movements
can be done in various
different ways, right?
The fightings are done in
various different ways.
Some people go on the street and protest.
Some people can write a book.
Some people can do something
else to promote certain agenda.
And I think Kim Iryŏp's
path was in a different way.
So here is one way of
explaining Kim Iryŏp's position
about women's movement.
When Kim Iryŏp joined
the monastery in 1928,
no, 1933, her master, Zen Master Man'gong,
who was very well-known Sŏn
master at the time, told her,
"I know you are a very
well-known writer and speaker
in the secular world outside.
If you join the monastery, you
don't read, you don't write.
Can you do it?"
I mean, if you are a writer,
you understand how difficult it is
for a writer not writing, right?
Kim Iryŏp said, "Yes."
And then she didn't publish, at least,
until late 1950s, so about.
She maintained it.
She kept this promise
for about two decades.
I was asked when I had an interview
with Kim Iryŏp's disciple, Wŏlsong sŭnim,
"Did she really didn't write anything?"
And then Wŏlsong sŭnim told me
that it looks like she wrote something,
but she never showed
her writings to anybody.
She didn't publish, right?
So anyway, she kept her promise.
Now, starting from late 1950s,
she began to publish again.
And the book that I translated,
(speaking in Korean) in Korean,
"Reflections of a Zen Buddhist
Nun," was published in 1960,
and then another book,
"Having Burned Away My Youth,"
(speaking in Korean),
was published in 1962.
And then the last book,
(speaking in Korean),
"In Between Happiness and Misfortune,"
was published in 1964.
Now, if you read these books,
you kind of, at first you get confused.
When I first read her
book, I was confused.
I'm reading a Buddhist nun's book.
And what you read there
is her love affairs.
Obviously, that happened
before she joined the monastery, right?
But she talk about her love affairs,
her friends' love affairs,
and so on and so forth.
What is going on here, right? (chuckles)
Where is Buddhist philosophy, right?
Now, if you really begin to
rethink about the situation
and try to digest what was
Kim Iryŏp trying to do here,
then you can get some
different kind of inspiration.
In the book, Kim Iryŏp
kind of talk a lot about
the life stories of various people,
including her own, right?
Lives and deaths of her family
members, her love affairs,
her friends' love affairs,
and the practice of
Christianity and Buddhism.
So in a way, it is biographical writing,
autobiographical writing,
biographical writing for her friends.
But once you begin to read
and think about the meaning of it,
and then, in between,
she kind of talk about
Buddhist philosophy, Buddhist doctrines.
At the beginning of the 1960 publication,
"Reflections of a Zen
Buddhist Nun," she says that,
in the preface, "Well, nowadays,
people do not want to think
about the serious things.
If we are trying to talk about religion,
they don't wanna read it.
So in order to kind of keep my reader,
I mixed my personal stories
with Buddhist doctrine,
and I made this bibimbap,"
right? (chuckles)
So that was her expression,
but I think there is a lot more than that.
So if you read the things (indistinct)
and then you begin to realize
that the diverse topics,
along with Iryŏp's unique way
of delivering Buddhist philosophy,
mark her books as an alternative
form of doing philosophy,
drawn from women's lives in the
milieus of daily experience.
If you are familiar with
a philosophy textbook,
the kind of standard philosophy book
you read in philosophy course,
there's no personal lives.
Philosophy is supposed to be about ideas
because philosophy should be universal.
Personal lives, personal
experience, is particular.
They cannot be universal.
That is a main assumption,
especially in modern European,
modern Western philosophy.
And if you apply that,
then you see that
there are many kind of aspects of life
that should be excluded in
philosophical discourse.
Life is not always about ideas.
There are a lot of messy things
going on in everyday life.
So Iryŏp writings are her way
of remembering existence in words.
By retelling her own life story
and those of her female friends,
Iryŏp made women's lives visible, right?
That is what writing does.
Your life is written, and then it's there,
instead of being forgotten,
showing that a woman's
life is not a disposable
and forgettable component
in a patriarchal society.
Her narratives are the
witnesses to her life
and the lives of other women.
This was Iryŏp's way of
engaging with women's issues.
And I think this is important aspects
of promoting women's agenda,
as much as explicitly saying that
"I'm engaged with women's movement,"
or go out and do protest.
There are different ways
of doing a protest, right?
So here I kind of place Kim
Iryŏp's life and thought
at three different kind of dimensions.
First, Kim Iryŏp's life and thought,
in the context of women and Buddhism,
which was the title of my talk.
And then, after that, you can think about,
in the context of intellectual
history of modern Korea,
because, definitely, Kim
Iryŏp should be there
in the intellectual history of Korea,
which has not been the case.
And then further, in the
context of the position
of non-Western philosophy
and women's philosophy
vis-à-vis male-centered and
West-centered philosophy.
I mean, if you have taken
any philosophy course,
tell me, how many women's
writings have you read?
How many non-Western
How many non-Western women's
writings have you read?
Here the answer is clear, right?
So there are a lot of kind
of philosophical arguments
you can make with that,
but one thing that you
can really think about
is what Miranda Fricker says,
that epistemic injustice.
When we talk about injustice,
we talk about social injustice,
when you are mistreated in a
society, in an institution.
But here, epistemic injustice
is the injustice that happens
before that social injustice,
visible form, happens.
In other words, because your mindset,
before you hear something,
you already made a
judgment about that person.
So when we hear about
the sexual harassment,
we always emphasize this, right,
it's not the victim's fault.
But there's always kind
of a pre-assumption,
that who's right, who's wrong.
So in this book, Miranda
Fricker talk about
two different types of
epistemic injustice.
The first one is hermeneutical injustice.
The second one is testimonial injustice.
Hermeneutical injustice has
to do with interpretation.
So quoting, "A gap in collective
interpretive resources
puts someone at an unfair disadvantage
when it comes to making sense
of their social experiences."
So when New Women talk about
their kind of experience
of society and injustice,
the society already made a judgment.
That's epistemic injustice, right?
Hermeneutical injustice. They
are not gonna listen to them.
The second one is testimonial injustice,
which occurs, quoting, "when
prejudice causes a hearer
to give a deflated level of credibility
to a speaker's word."
In other words, you hear
some woman's experience
and, "Okay, that makes sense,
but that's not as important
as what is said by my male
colleague," for example.
This is what we always,
still, kind of experience.
And then, the New Women
phenomenon in Korea
or Kim Iryŏp's life itself
really shows us how this
type of epistemic injustice
really kind of constrained women's life
and many people who are at the margin.
In a patriarchal Korean Buddhism,
Iryŏp's position in modern Korean Buddhism
demonstrates the patriarchal
nature of Korean Buddhism
that continues to refuse to acknowledge
the importance of women's
search for identity
and existential value, and
the practice continues today.
In Korea, I wrote in English.
So I published a book
about Kim Iryŏp in English.
But in Korea, there is no publication
about Kim Iryŏp's Buddhism.
Nobody studies it, right?
Even nowadays, they do not
think Kim Iryŏp is important.
She's just somebody who
talk about love affairs.
So when I translate that
book, Kim Iryŏp's first book,
"Reflections of a Zen Master,"
that book was supported
by Korean kind of government project.
When that book was selected,
in Korea, people said,
"Why do we need to translate a woman
who talk about love affairs?"
The only reason that book survived
was the person who's in
charge of that translation
was Robert Buswell, who
Prof. Kim mentioned,
the big figure in Korean Buddhism.
And Robert Buswell
said, "We should do it."
And Korean people just said, "Yes," right?
Otherwise, I don't think
it will ever happen,
which shows that still
there's no kind of a scholarship
on Kim Iryŏp's Buddhism itself.
And silencing and silenced.
The voices of the New Women, or of women,
have been silenced in Korean society,
not only in the 1920s but
for decades until the 1990s,
when women scholars
began to rediscover them.
So New Women's stories were not discussed
in academic setting until 1990s in Korea.
In between, in Korea,
there was always excuses.
There was colonialism,
there was Korean War,
there was economic development,
and so on and so forth,
which should be more
important than women's issue,
which is nothing from Korean perspective.
That's why that women's voice is not there
in intellectual history
of modern Korea, right?
Where do we find the women's voices
in intellectual history of modern Korea?
So Iryŏp writings and life
reveal one of the missing parts
in this history.
And the third aspect
is the new style of philosophizing.
So as Prof. Kim mentioned
before, when he introduced me,
I call Kim Iryŏp's philosophy,
narrative philosophy.
So narrative philosophy is not something
just to kind of discuss ideas,
but this is a philosophy
in which we talk about,
narrate about one's experience,
and from there, trying to construct
the meaning of existence.
One of the reasons women
have been undervalued
in the traditional philosophy
is because women's life
events have been taken
out of the context of their lives
and become objects of judgment
based on the standards
established from patriarchal perspective.
Therefore, the women's stories
are always about household life,
and then that's nothing.
This kind of attitude really pushed women
outside of domain of philosophy.
The non-Western philosophy and religion
in the Western academia has
been treated as inferior
because they do not fit it
in the standard and the style
of Western philosophy.
But why should Western
philosophy be the standard
for philosophizing, right?
And Iryŏp's books show us how
narrative of women's lives
help us understand women's lives
and different forms of meaning production,
based on the life stories.
So in a way, just to
kind of, as a conclusion,
our research on Kim Iryŏp awakens us
to the double or triple discrimination
in our society and scholarship.
In the context of Korean Studies,
the complete disregard
of Kim Iryŏp's Buddhism
in Korean Buddhist community
and Buddhist scholarship
demonstrates the patriarchal nature
of Buddhism practiced in Korea,
as well as in the Korean
Buddhist scholarship
and academic community.
In the context of intellectual
history of modern Korea,
silencing of women's voices
reveal the incapacity
of Korean society and scholarship
to deal with diversity of human endeavor
to creatively find meaning
in existence and community.
So I think the kind of silence
and the tradition of
silencing different voices
throughout 20th century, obviously kind of
lack Korean society the capacity
to deal with these different
voices now in 21st century,
and society became more and more rigid.
On the other hand, Iryŏp's
Buddhism offers us a way
for women to engage with Buddhism
in their search for freedom and identity.
So Buddhism can be thought of
within the context of a
woman's search for freedom.
Iryŏp's narrative philosophy and Buddhism
that is based on the experience
of women's daily life
offers an alternative to
the dominant philosophy
and thought tradition in the academia
that exclusively validates West-centered
and male-dominated philosophizing.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Moderator] Thank you so
much for such an engaging talk.
Yeah, let's go over to questions.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much.
This was really interesting.
I would really love to
hear more about her concept
of the great-I.
Just how does she sort
of explain this concept?
Is it something similar
to, like, Buddha-nature?
Is she engaging like a kind of absolute
versus conventional truth binary?
Like, yeah, what is the
great-I that she explains?
- That's a very good question, right?
So you used this kind of a
Buddhist vocabulary, right?
Conventional and ultimate,
or the Buddha-nature.
I think that is what
Kim Iryŏp was thinking.
But interesting, another interesting part
of Kim Iryŏp's Buddhism
is that she rarely uses
Buddhist vocabulary.
She uses it in her own way.
So great-I, I explained the great-I here
a little bit more
socially-engaged concept.
She put it in a very
abstract way sometimes,
which is great-I is the I of nothingness.
So that is part of it, right?
So in a way, it has to do with emptiness,
total openness of being.
So one of the expressions she used
is the root of nothingness,
(speaking in Korean),
the root of nothingness, that
is a foundation of existence,
and that is great-I,
which is I
before the thought of I arises.
Does it make sense?
I, openness-I, before the thought of I
are letting in the second I,
then you have a kind of boundary arises.
And she uses this expression a lot:
a thought before a thought arises.
So the first thought is
this kind of total openness
of our (indistinct) thought thinking,
whereas thought before a thought arises...
When thought arises, already
this thought was compromised.
We already see things from
kind of our own perspective.
When I look at the water bottle,
I already see it as "I
can drink water," right?
Instead of, "I don't know
what water bottle want to be
(chuckles) except it being drinken by me."
But that kind of idea, right?
Total openness.
So, yeah, so that's true.
It could be Buddha-nature, and
in an ultimate sense, right,
at the ultimate level.
So conventional level perhaps is limited,
but then ultimate level...
But she rarely uses that
Buddhist expressions,
Buddhist vocabularies.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- Sure.
- [Moderator] Another question?
- [Audience Member] Thank you
so much for speaking with us.
I just wanted to ask,
could you talk more about
what were the influences in the 1950s
that made Kim Iryŏp start writing again
and trying to share her thoughts?
- Mm-mm, mm-mm. That's a good question.
So my interpretation is that, by 1950s,
I think Iryŏp became
confident about herself.
So when she joined the monastery,
so she joined the monastery in 1933,
that year, she had an interview
with the journal called
"Opening of the World," the "Kyebyŏk."
And there, she said something like,
"I became, I practice Buddhism
so then I can be a better
writer, like the Buddha."
So she thought that
writing, doing the writing
before you really, fully
become a human being,
that's nothing, you should not do it.
"So I'm practicing Buddhism,
so then I can be a great writer
like the Buddha himself."
So she invested this time, about 20 years,
more than 20 years,
to really think about
what it means to exist,
what is freedom, and so on and so forth.
So by mid-1950s, she
must have felt confident,
"Now I can do the writing without kind of
being tempted by fame,"
and so on and so forth.
I mean, if you are a writer,
partly there is also that
kind of aspect, right?
"I want to be famous, I
want to be a celebrity,"
and so on and so forth.
So I think that by the
time she's in her sixties
and she became confident about herself,
and she also talk about
Christianity, right?
Yeah, so that's my interpretation.
There is no, as far as I
know, I read almost everything
Kim Iryŏp wrote that are available, right,
and there is no indication
that there was any instant
that made her kind of publish her works.
So if there's nothing like that,
then it's a kind of gradual training.
She trained herself for 20 years,
and then, by that time,
she perhaps thought that,
"Well, now I can do it again. Go back."
Right. Yeah.
- [Audience Member] I was
also really interested
in the small-I and great-I
as Buddhist concepts,
and building on the last
question about that,
it seems to me like the soa, the small-I,
is this self that's still constrained
by the assumption of conventional truth,
and the tae'a, the great-I, is more,
(indistinct) still a conventional self,
because there ultimately is no-self,
but it's sort of overcome that.
You've you reached that enlightenment,
so beyond the (indistinct).
- Right, right, right, right.
- [Audience Member] So I
think that is very helpful
in thinking about these
Buddhist terms about, like,
what it is to get beyond
a conventional truth.
And this was kind of coming
up here in your talk,
in instances of, like,
overcoming the constraints
of concepts like gender.
And on the self,
I can see that happening
on the individual level,
realizing, "Okay, I'm not
constrained by these things,"
but what about on the larger social level?
And it's the same problem we
run into with critical theory.
We can talk about critical theory,
but if we don't get those
who are out there in society,
in positions of power,
positions of influence,
spreading information,
to see beyond the conventional
truth, that of concepts,
how is the violence stopped getting done?
Is there anything implicit
or explicit in her writing
that points to that,
or is it strictly a
self-enlightenment, cultivation thing?
- So I can answer that
in two different ways.
First one, no, she doesn't talk
about social issue that much
after she joined the monastery, right?
So her great-I is a very
much individual level
of enlightenment issue, right?
But then she also offer it to any woman
who wants to be free.
Any individual who want
to lead a creative life
should really be trying to
exercise this great-I, right?
So on the one hand,
that is an invitation to self-cultivation
so that that person can be a
valuable member of a society.
And actually, in one of the book panels
about Kim Iryŏp's book,
Leah Kalmanson, who does
Japanese Zen Buddhism, actually,
she wrote a kind of article
about Kim Iryŏp and feminism.
And there she said that,
well, meditation is not an
individual event, right?
Because by doing meditation,
you want to be a better person.
You want to achieve a
certain type of state
which cannot be just limited by yourself,
especially in Buddhism, when
everything is connected.
If one person reached a certain state,
that person's capacity will illuminate
and have an influence on others.
Therefore meditation
is a political action.
That's what she said.
And in a way, that is a good way of seeing
the influence of religion
or the self-cultivation,
even though in our society that
type of invisible influence
is not that much valued.
We always want to see something, right,
and grasp it.
So a tangible, visible way.
But I think that's an important aspect.
On the other hand, it's true.
Kim Iryŏp has been criticized
for lack of that clear social vision,
like Zen Buddhism has been, right?
Zen Buddhism has been
criticized because of that.
And Kim Iryŏp was
criticized for that, too.
In a way I'm defending Kim Iryŏp
to bring this meditation
as a social, political action,
and so and so forth.
I think both are true,
from my perspective.
So my parent generation, my aunt,
they said that after Kim Iryŏp's
first book was published,
many young Korean women joined
the monastery. (chuckles)
So, you know, that shows
the kind of influence of this woman.
And well, actually,
after I published the
translation of Kim Iryŏp's book,
the Korean community in
Washington, D.C., where I live,
they gave me a small book party,
that everybody-knows-everybody party.
So about 20 people joined
to celebrate the publication
of Kim Iryŏp's book.
But that event was kind of
announced on Korean newspaper.
It's not a kind of invitation,
but anybody can come.
But anyway, and then at the party,
one older lady and young woman came.
Nobody knew who they were,
so we were asking,
"Who's that? Who's that?
Who's that?", right? (chuckles)
So after kind of a while
later, we asked the lady,
"So how did you get to
know of this event?"
And she said, daughter says that,
"My mother saw the
announcement on the newspaper
and she told me, 'We should go there.'"
And then she said, "My
mother doesn't read English."
But she said, the mother said that,
"Kim Iryŏp was the woman in my generation
who led the life which we couldn't do,
but we wanted to live."
Kim Iryŏp was the one who
led a life of freedom,
searching for her own identity.
Even though she was not
able to live like that,
but she really admire her.
Therefore she wanted to
come to book party, right?
So for me, that was really, really,
there was a real inspiration.
I mean, that shows the kind
of influence of Kim Iryŏp
on a certain generation of Korean women.
But it was not only Korean women.
My parent generation,
male admire Kim Iryŏp as a
kind of cool girl. (chuckles)
(audience chuckles)
Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much.
There's a lot to think
about from your comments.
I'd like to ask a question from
the perspective of language,
being a writer, language issues,
linguistics more broadly,
leading into concepts and notions
from a philosophical perspective.
Understanding that you
know her work so well,
I think you're in a position
to be able to assess or intuit
to what degree her language itself
changed over that 20-year hiatus.
She were wrote before, and
then she wrote afterward,
and then she wrote afterward
from a state of having realized something.
And we all know that language
itself poses the same problems
that we encounter in a
broader philosophical sense.
What pronouns you choose.
We grapple with this today
in English.
- That's right, yeah.
- [Audience Member] And every
language family is different.
- Right, yeah.
- [Audience Member] But
there are identifiers
for language spoken by women
and language spoken by
men across societies.
Did she, I'm just curious
whether you sensed
any difference in her writing,
in the way that she spoke
of herself, to begin with,
and otherwise, grammatical issues,
just choices of what pronoun
to use, perhaps?
- That's a-
- [Audience Member] I'm
more familiar with Japanese,
but you can make choices
about how you refer to
yourself in a more neutral way
or as a really very feminine way
of pronouncing something and so on.
- Right. Yeah, that's a great question.
Now I think about that issue.
So before she joined a monastery,
she wrote mostly poetry or short stories
and couple of short polemics
about women's issue.
And there it's more like a
argumentative tone, right,
and claiming women's issue.
Or, she faced a lot of
death in the family.
She lost all the immediate
family before she reached 20.
So she talked a lot about this agony,
about losing family members.
She wrote in poetry. She
wrote in short story.
So that was before she
joined the monastery.
So in the later books, I have
to say, there is some things,
a little bit of urgency in the later book
when she talk about Buddhism.
So actually, this semester,
in my seminar, we read Kim Iryŏp's book,
and then some student says
that, "She's pushing us.
She's pushing us and philosophy
shouldn't be that way."
And I was thinking, "What does that mean,
that she's pushing us?"
And in a way, that's what I
think that urgency in that book.
I mean, "You should do this,
but why are you not doing it?"
And that is kind of her sense of urgency
and that's distinctive
in the later writing.
And she uses a lot of her
own way of expressing things.
And sometimes, even in Korean,
sometimes it doesn't make sense, right?
I mean, I don't know whether
it was a kind of printing
quality at the time,
but there's some passages
in the book that I translated that,
they didn't make sense in Korean.
And when you translate it, you
have to translate it, right?
And I couldn't make sense of it (chuckles)
from the Korean original.
So I translated literally,
and my copy-editor of the publisher
at the University of Hawaii, emailed me,
"Jin, this does not
make sense in English."
And I said, "It does not
make sense in Korean either.
(audience chuckling)
(chuckles) What am I supposed to do?"
But in a way, there's a kind
of mixture of her creativity,
and then, like her use of expression,
her own expression to interpret Buddhism.
So this urgency
and the creative use of her expressions
in interpreting Buddhism,
I think that, mostly,
they are distinctive for me, at least.
That's a good question I
will think about more, yeah.
- [Audience Member] Oh, yeah, thank you.
Thanks for really a wonderful talk.
I'm afraid I'm very
ignorant about this subject,
so my question is a bit maybe basic.
But I was just wondering to what extent,
you mentioned at the beginning
that there are actually more female nuns
than monks in Korea,
and that just stands out
in contrast to your comment
about, you know, kind of
the stereotypical view
of Kim Iryŏp being that
she went to a monastery
and that was like the
failure of her life, right?
So I'm just wondering whether
either kind of alongside
Kim Iryŏp's time as a nun
or sort of after that,
ideas about being a nun
have changed in Korea or
whether there are other women
who've taken the (indistinct)
in Korean society
and whether that has
taken on new meanings,
or are there, like, alternative visions
of what being a nun means
in kind of postwar Korean society?
- Right, that's a very
good question, right?
So as you know, religion had
its own function in a society,
in pre-modern society.
For example, monastery was
not only a religious space.
It was orphanage, it was
a senior citizens' home.
After you get old,
if you don't have a family
to take care of you,
you join the monastery.
If you're an orphan, you are
taken care of by the monastery.
So monastery had various
different social function
as they are.
But in modern society,
monastery gradually began
to lose that function.
Also, monastery or religion
had not only this kind of social function,
but it had a kind of special
position in a society,
because religious world,
which is sacred world,
is separate from secular world.
Therefore they had its own
privilege in pre-modern society.
Modern society kind of get
rid of this distinction.
So monastery or religious
organization needed to justify
its own kind of
contribution to the society.
And for women, one of the key benefits,
from even Buddha's time, to
join the monastery was education
and getting away from this
family household life.
But gradually, gradually,
when women kind of get a
opportunity to get educated,
the benefit of joining the
monastery kind of diminishes.
Actually, when I visited Kim Iryŏp place,
one of Kim Iryŏp's disciples asked me,
because I've been kind of
doing research on Kim Iryŏp,
"Why didn't you join the monastery?"
And then she answered her own question,
"Oh, nowadays you don't have to
because you can get educated anyway."
So that was a main issue.
And because of that, Korean society,
after especially the mid-20th century,
began to see those people
who joined the monastery
as somebody who failed in
a secular world, right?
If you are good in secular world,
why do you join the monastery?
And actually, that book that I translated,
Kim Iryŏp's disciple,
who served Kim Iryŏp until her last day,
she was the one who
kind of helped Kim Iryŏp
to publish that book,
has a short kind of essay of her own.
She says that when she was
trying to join the monastery,
her family, her parents,
her brothers, her siblings,
they all cried.
And then she said, "I pity them
because why are they crying, right,
because I'm going to monastery
to find something bigger."
So in a way, there is a gap, kind of gap,
between the society's
perception of those people
who join the monastery
and those people who're
joining the monastery.
And obviously, in both monks and nuns,
the number of monastics
are kind of diminishing,
the overall case.
But I think the women's case
is still that joining the monastery
was to find their own kind of life
outside of this family
setting or household setting.
But nowadays, I don't think that people
would say that explicitly, right?
"You joined the monastery
because you failed," right?
But that kind of the idea was there.
And Robert Buswell said the
same thing about Buddhist monks
in his book, "Zen Monastic
Experience," right,
when he joined the monastery in 1970s.
And then people, Korean people thought
that there are kind of
three type of Korean monks,
men who joined the monastery.
First, a failure in a society.
Second one was who was not happy
with Western philosophy. (chuckles)
So they think that the
Asian philosophy was better.
What was the third one?
I forgot, but there was a third one,
so that kind of lazy people. (chuckles)
So that was his categorization.
But in a way, so there is
a mixed kind of reaction.
Nowadays, I don't think
that people explicitly say
that you failed because
you joined a monastery,
but there was that kind of thing.
But those people who joined the monastery,
obviously they have
the bigger goal.
Well, actually, a couple of years ago
when I had a conference in Taiwan,
there is a Huayan school,
which I regularly go for a conference.
There was a young, very young Buddhist nun
who just joined the monastery
after she finished college.
And since my Chinese is not
good enough to communicate,
she was interpreting for me,
and I just asked this
stupid question, right?
"So you joined the monastery.
Do you like it?" (chuckles)
And then she was all smiling
and said, "I love it."
And then at that moment I realized that,
yeah, there are people
who really are searching
for something which is bigger
than we do in a secular society.
And the monastery is not
totally separate nowadays
and they are all (indistinct), yeah.
- [Moderator] (indistinct)
question will be the last one.
- [Audience Member] Thank you very much.
I was wondering if you
could tell us a bit more
about Kim Iryŏp's ideas about culture.
You mentioned that culture
is like the full expression of creativity,
but at the same time, isn't
like culture and society
imposing on people's ability to, like,
fully find their own
creativity and express that?
So how did she work that out
in her writing (indistinct)?
- Why, that's a very good question.
So she challenged this
patriarchal culture, right,
but she used this expression.
I'm yet to find where is the source
of her use of this
expression, "culture," right?
This "culture" also,
I believe the East Asian expression,
(speaking in foreign language),
that is a translation from
Western language that,
like many expressions, that
came from Western society
and along with modernization.
So Kim Iryŏp's idea of a culture
is the full exercise of creativity.
And when this creativity
culminates, right,
at the culmination of creativity,
you see certain more tangible
results, and that is culture.
So for example, cultural artifacts, right?
So nice building, old building at Yale,
that's culture, right,
in which all the spirit of the human mind
is kind of condensed.
But that's a good point.
Kim Iryŏp didn't see culture as something
which can also impose
pressure from outside.
But there has been some discussion
about this different way
of taking this expression, "culture."
So Western, in the European
expression, culture,
English "culture" came from
French "cultivate," right?
So cultivate, like cultivating crop,
so that's why we say "cultivation."
Whereas East Asian tradition
didn't get that one.
But (speaking in Chinese) is writing,
but the second character,
Chinese character,
(speaking in Chinese),
(speaking in Korean) in Korean,
then means transformation.
And there, I think, we
can find a similar idea
of cultivation in English,
in the European language,
and then transformation.
And I think that's part
of Kim Iryŏp's idea
about transforming yourself
through creative activity.
But I think that your
question's really valid
in asking that.
While she resisted patriarchal culture,
but she didn't call that as a culture.
And I think it also,
this requires a little
bit historical survey
of the evolution of the concept,
because this expression,
"culture," itself,
came to Korea, I think, just
at the end of 19th century,
and by the time of Kim Iryŏp's
use of that expression,
what would be the dominant
concept of culture, right?
So, but yeah.
- [Moderator] Thank you so
much for your wonderful talk.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)